uh the top men's player in world tennis
novak djokovic has had his australian
visa cancelled for the second time uh
let's have a quick look we have been
hearing uh from the australian prime
minister scott morrison here is his
statement
i note the minister for immigration's
decision in relation to mr novak
djokovic's visa i understand that
following careful consideration action
has been taken by the minister to cancel
the visa held on health and good order
grounds on the basis it was in the
public interest to do so he continues
the pandemic has been incredibly
difficult for every australian but we
have stuck together and saved lives and
livelihoods
uh let's bring in skies news australia's
julia bradley who joins us now from
melbourne julia good to see you again do
hope you're well so what happens next is
it taxi for novak djokovic
well there are a number of options here
neil so as it stands world number one
tennis player novak djokovic he is set
to be detained and deported from
australia and also banned from entering
the country for the next three years but
there are still a number of options for
the lawyers representing novak djokovic
so they could now decide to challenge
this decision in court over the weekend
and then they could also request an
injunction which could potentially allow
him to stay in the country
and also possibly play in the australian
open so there are a number of options
for the lawyers to consider and we
understand that they are now considering
all of those options following this
statement from the immigration minister
here in australia alex cork saying that
this decision has been made he's used
his special powers to be able to cancel
the visa of novak djokovic for a second
time now as you know this is really a
saga that's drawn the eyes of the world
it sparked much debate over the course
of the past week we've heard from some
people who are fearful that this could
in fact
look bad for australia on the world
stage cancelling the visa of the world
number one tennis player but there is
also rising sentiment here in australia
that he should in fact be deported and
that that would be the right thing to do
given that we've had such tough border
measures during the course of this
pandemic so that decision are coming
through from our immigration minister
just a number of hours ago we are still
waiting to see what kind of reaction
there is among the community here in
melbourne we've seen a protest during
that first decision to cancel the visa
of novak djokovic so we are waiting to
see whether there's any unrest tonight
particularly within the serbian
community here in melbourne but
certainly a long-awaited decision from
the federal immigration department that
decision coming through a number of
hours ago that novak's visa will be
cancelled as it stands he is set to be
detained and then deported